[Music]
crash course philosophy is brought to
you by Squarespace Squarespace share
your passion with the world what gives
your life meaning God love money work
fanfiction football shopping Sherlock
you might have your own personal sense
of purpose in your life or maybe you're
hoping this course will help you find
one or you might believe that you were
created with a certain Essence as a
human being with a purpose given to you
by God whatever the case is no one would
fault you for wanting your life to have
meaning a sense of meaning is something
that we all crave maybe even need and as
we move out of our unit on the
philosophy of religion we should spend
some time talking about how we
understand our lives as being meaningful
cuz when you think about it a lot of us
devote a ton of energy to the task of
finding meaning in our lives maybe you
find it through religion or by fighting
for social justice or educating others
or seeking Beauty and artistic
expression no matter how you do it
there's a group of philosophers the
existentialists who say that any or all
of these things can give your life
meaning but at the same time they say
none of them can
[Music]
as you know by now philosophy is about
the dialectic someone puts forth an idea
and then someone else responds to it
sometimes the response comes right away
in other cases it takes thousands of
years way back in ancient Greece Plato
and Aristotle took it as given that
everything has an Essence a certain set
of core properties that are necessary or
essential for a thing to be what it is
if those properties were Miss missing
then that thing would be a different
thing for instance a knife could have a
wooden handle or a metal handle it
really doesn't matter but if it didn't
have a blade it wouldn't really be a
knife anymore the blade is the essential
property of the knife because it gives
the knife its defining function now
Plato and Aristotle thought that
everything has an Essence including us
and they believe that our Essences exist
in us before we're even born so by this
thinking part of what it means to be a
good human is to adhere to your essence
now you may or may not know what your
essence is and you might be great at
Living up to your essence or you may be
awful at it but the important thing is
that your essence gives you a purpose
because you were born to be a certain
thing this belief known as essentialism
was the standard view of the universe
all the way up until the late 19th
century and it's still accepted by many
people today but in the late 1800s some
thinkers started to challenge the idea
that we are imbued with any essence or
purpose German philosopher Friedrich
nche for example embraced nihilism the
belief in the ultimate meaninglessness
of life but by the mid- 20th century the
path had been paved for French thinker
Jean Paul SRA to return to the question
of essence and ask what if we exist
first what if we're born without any
hardwired purpose and then it's up to us
to figure out our own Essences well this
became the framework for what we now
know as existentialism and its Mantra is
the claim that existence precedes
essence in other words our existence our
birth happens first then it's up to each
of us to determine who we are we have to
write our own Essence through the way we
choose to live but we have no actual
predetermined purpose there's no set
path that we're supposed to follow it's
hard to express how radical this idea
was at the time because for thousands of
years before this you didn't have to
choose a path or find your purpose God
did it for you but it's important to
note that existentialism is not
synonymous with atheism plenty of
existentialists are atheists but some
are theists like kirkgard what theistic
existentialists deny is any sort of
tileology that is they refute the notion
that God made the universe or our world
or us with any particular purpose in
mind so God may exist but instilling you
or your life or the Cosmos with meaning
that's just not in his job description
as a result we are each born into a
universe in which we and our world and
our actions lack any real inherent
importance this is a fundamental
component of existentialism and its
adherence refer to it as the Absurd you
and I think of absurdity as something
that's just silly or Preposterous but
for existentialists absurdity is a
technical term it's how they describe
the search for answers in an answerless
world we are creatures who need meaning
but we are abandoned in a universe full
of meaninglessness so we cry Into the
Wilderness and get no response but we
keep crying anyway that for an
existentialist is the definition of
absurd since there's no thology the
world wasn't created for a reason and it
doesn't exist for a reason and if
there's no reason for any of this then
there's also no absolutes to abide by
there's no Cosmic Justice no fairness no
order no rules now existentialism has
its roots in late 19th century thinkers
like kirkgard and N but it really came
into its own during and after World War
II as the horrors of the Holocaust led
many people to abandon any belief in an
ordered world and who could blame them
when Nazis became possible meaning
became much harder to find but SRA faced
meaninglessness head-on and explored one
of the most agonizing aspects of
existentialism not the world's lack of
meaning but it's terrifying abundance of
freedom to most of us freedom sounds
pretty great but sarra thought that we
are painfully shockingly free after all
if there are no guidelines for our
actions then each of us is forced to
design our own moral code to invent a
morality to live by sarra took this to
mean that we are condemned to be free a
fate that he found to be quite awful you
might think that there's some Authority
you could look to for answers SRA said
but all of the authorities you can think
of are fake you can do what your parents
say or your church or your government
but serer said those authorities are
really just people like you people who
don't have any answers people who had to
figure out for themselves how to live so
the best thing you can really do he
determined is to live authentically sry
used this to mean that you have to
accept the full weight of your freedom
in light of the Absurd you have to
recognize that any meaning your life has
is given to it by you and if you decide
to just phone it in and follow a path
that someone else has set whether it's
your teachers your government or your
religion then you have what he called
bad faith a refusal to accept the Absurd
if you live by bad faith you're burying
your head in the sand and pretending
that something out there has meaning
meaning that you didn't give it which
brings us to this week's flash
philosophy let's go to the the thought
bubble Sara explained these ideas
through an anecdote about one of his
students who faced a difficult decision
the young man was at a Crossroads in his
life he could join the military during
wartime and go off and fight for a cause
that he believed in and he wanted to do
this he thought it was right but he also
had an elderly mother who was all alone
except for him if he went to war he'd
leave her behind and that seemed wrong
so he could stay with her and let others
fight for justice or he could go off to
war and leave his mother to herself and
likely never see her again the young man
felt a sense of Duty to both his cause
and to his mother but he could only
serve one moreover if he went to war
he'd just be a very small part of a
really big cause his contribution
probably wouldn't be great but he would
be contributing to something that would
affect millions of people but if he
stayed behind he'd make an enormous
difference in just one person's life
thanks thought bubble so what's the
answer sarer said the whole point of
this young man's decision was that no
one could give him an answer in fact
there was no answer until the man chose
one for himself no moral theory could
help him decide because no one else's
advice could lead him to a decision that
was truly authentic so his choice no
matter what it was was the only true
Choice provided that he made it
authentically because it was determined
by the values he chose to accept a lot
of people think existentialism paints a
pretty bleak picture of the world in
fact the French philosopher and novelist
Alber Kimu went so far as to say that
the literal meaning of life is whatever
you're doing that prevents you from
killing yourself but most
existentialists would remind you that
the world and your life can have meaning
but only if you choose to assign it if
the world is inherent ly devoid of
purpose you can choose to imbue it with
whatever purpose you want so no one can
tell you if your life isn't worth
anything if you say don't have children
or don't follow a lucrative career path
or achieve whatever standards your
parents hold you to and this works not
just on an individual scale but on a
global one too if the world is going to
have any of the things most of us value
like justice and Order we're going to
have to put it there ourselves because
otherwise those things wouldn't exist so
a worldview that looks bleak to some may
to others seem almost exhilarating today
I hope you enjoyed a as much as I did
learning about essentialism and its
response existentialism we talked about
John Paul SRA and his ideas about how to
find meaning in a meaningless world this
episode was brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace helps to create
websites blogs or online stores for you
and your ideas websites look
professionally designed regardless of
skill level no coding required try
Squarespace at squarespace.com
crashcourse for a special offer
Squarespace share your passion with the
world crash course philosophy is
produced in association with PBS digital
Studios you can head over to their
channel to check out amazing shows like
the chatter boox PBS SpaceTime and PBS
idea Channel this episode of Crash
Course was filmed in the Dr Cheryl C
Kenny crash course studio with the help
of all these awesome people and our
equally fantastic Graphics team is
thought Cafe